so it's been a long time since I last
played duck chess
but it still exists
and it's going to take a bit of
concentration to adjust from
[Music]
basically transitioning from normal
chest to duck chests
if you're new to duck chess
this is something I streamed a while ago
there is a big craze but it's basically
normal chess with inclusion of a duck
every move
basically consists of two steps you make
a normal chest move and then you move
the duck to a different empty Square
and the duck is a blocker so light can't
move through the duck can't capture the
duck
and hopefully that all makes sense
there's a few other rules like the game
ends by capturing the king
and there's really no
official concept of check
so if the Kings attacked you can still
Castle which
is useful to keep in mind
and I'm employing the strategy of
putting the duck in front of the t-pawn
because I don't want the bishop to
develop I don't want white to control
too much Center
develop in a
hopefully somewhat harmonious way
ah
yeah I can't promise that
I won't be chasing waterfowl
but we'll see
I think I'll play E6 and then duck
let's keep putting the duck back here
I want to play D5 next
fight for some sector
are you still one of the highest rated
players in Duck chess
my rating is 2316. I can check after
this game
if uh what the case with my rating is
or can I click here
maybe I can reconfigure the scene so
people can see
actually
I'll do it after this game
okay that's a slightly annoying Square
for the duck but
I think I can cope
and let's still prevent the pawn from
moving and the Bishop from developing
oh I can't Castle
[Music]
yeah every single turn this game I've
put the duck back on D3
I'm being very stubborn with my duck
and one strategy in Duck chess is just
uh
like try and Achieve good pieces
be ready for a long fight
sometimes duck chess games
they're a lot more strategic
but
things might get quaktical pretty soon
I think I'll take the Knight
because
yeah Bishops should be or uh Knights are
generally more powerful than Bishops in
this game
I put the duck on D4
and the reason for that is I want to
guarantee myself Pawn D for next move
I think
lights debating which thing to take with
I might be winning on time very soon
not sure what happened to my opponent
oh Pawn takes
Okay so
I see aquatic I'm gonna play this and
then this
almost trapping the Knight essentially
forcing the Knight to trade for the
bishop
and then I'll have two knights against
two Bishops
hey I just joined today is he playing
Duchess
yes I am
you're the duck
okay preventing Bishop takes Knights
oh
defend
in pretty solid position
and I'll play this
the square is really nice it prevents
Queen E4
um I'll keep putting the duck back on e4
trying to orchestrate some attack
oh wait a minute wait wait wait
if I play this
I think what I do oh there's a really
beautiful line I'm gonna play Knight H4
and duck F3
that way I guarantee Knight F3 so
whatever white chooses to take
I fork
and I'm not mating
but I'm winning the queen
now I take the queen
and I'll block the
block The Rook from hitting the knights
okay
so opponent got low on time
but hopefully that's a nice refresher on
the strategy and Classics of duck chess
wait could I have taken the king
oh I could have taken the king
I was so focused on winning the queen
oops
that's one of those things like
transitioning to duck chess I'm not used
to the opponent just leaving the king
hanging
so
okay I can play more people we'll go in
order here
playing NADA Bots
please make this duck Chaz VOD into a
YouTube video
it's not a bad idea
um yeah if you're watching in the future
on YouTube
let me know if you want to see more duck
chess
I did see a lot of people in the YouTube
comments like asking for duck chess
uh in a recent video I posted so
hopefully this content will satisfy
those people
okay employing maybe a slightly
different opening strategy
preventing the female cattle
gonna develop the knights
um I'm gonna block the bishop I didn't
want to allow Bishop G4
do we need to give this opponent a
Turing test
that's uh
that's a clever comment
we'll we'll see based on this game how
human-like they play
or how duck-like they are
okay so I could take the knights
I could also take the pawn
yeah let's take the pawn
and then I'll block the attack of the
queen
and yeah the knight's ready to capture
do you have to capture the king
not just attack yeah the game ends with
capturing the king even if the king like
is technically checkmated
um
yeah that's why capturing king or
flagging or resignation
so
opponent wants to take my knight
interesting
I think I just have to allow it
I could play uh Knight A4 maybe Knight
A4
but then queen bee for check
if I played duck before there's Queen A5
check
so how about I take
I was very clever move from luck
there's actually a lot of things are
attacked and the duck can only stop
so much
so
what to do
Bishop E2
and I'll still block the queen
if takes takes at least I activate the
bishop
welcome back Roker time flies when
you're watching International chess
master and you're happy two years thank
you for all your amazing work two years
let's go appreciate that
are you winning son
I mean the battle is heating up I'm down
a little bit of time
um yeah just over a minute opponent has
just over 90 seconds
we could get into like sometime some
kind of time scramble
okay so I'll take with Bishop
and
I could block I'm probably gonna lose a
d-pawn
I think I'd rather lose a d-pawn than
the b-pong
I can still take the Knight when I want
but yeah to reiterate checks are um
are not always forcing in this variation
or this um yeah this variant
all right let's block the bishop now
but of course usually when your kings
attacked you should get out of it
I mean I could play this move
let's play this move
I'm blocking the bishop so no Bishop
takes Knights
I am allowing this
but then things could get very messy
where like everything's hanging
maybe I played this move
guaranteeing Knight C7
now there's a lot of targets the queen
The Rook the Knight of course the king
the Bishops are actually very strong
here
positions opened up
together
okay now I can do this and
probably this
Chase the king towards the center
and I'll win The Rook next
I have to watch out for my time
I'm gonna lose my Rook like there's
takes in Duck B1
it should be okay
so here's a situation I can Castle
um yeah let's castle and then this
saving the Rook
or both very low on time but
okay
I think black was in trouble in the
final position
so let me um
try and wow a lot of people want to play
duck chess
bear with me one moment I'm gonna get
the thing to display
so we have the rules here
and then
um yeah we can see the move list here
so who's the highest rated player
challenging me
oh raiding anxiety rated 1800
okay good luck
quack and Quack
all right so let's go this this way
yeah there's high demand for challenges
so just have to be patient and a little
bit lucky
so I'm trying to show no mercy
I'm gonna go for
full central control
um yeah G6 duck G7 is an interesting
approach to
guaranteed Bishop G7
but I'm okay with that
now there's a trap here if black goes
for this move which looks enticing I was
gonna play Knight G5 duck F3
but now what to do
be this move and then this move
so I'm guaranteeing Pawn H5
foreign
yeah the issue with the challenge is at
least in the duck chess server is
um they go away once I start a game
so it'd be hard to track like the
overall cue
that's interesting so if I play H5
Black's gonna play G5
maybe just Bishop E3
Queen D3
the reason for Queen D3 is sometimes a
short range defense is a bit more
effective than the longer range defense
okay
yeah this opponent definitely
understands some strategy
but do they understand quatics
so this is a very tricky idea because
the duck is going to have to go away
from C6
which means my Bishop will be Unleashed
along this diagonal
but I I guess I'm not winning anything
[Music]
feels like I'm close though
maybe this
okay creating this battery
yeah you can't leave the duck on the
same square
that's a very big component uh
where you should put the duck
because sometimes you want to use the
duck to prevent your opponent from doing
things
but other times you want to use the duck
to guarantee yourself
to do things on the next move
so I play duck C6 to try and allow for
Queen C6 next
but I'm also having ideas with queen A6
so that has to be really really careful
here
and it might already be
like losing material for that
because I'm gonna play this
and then this
so preventing Queen c8s
and the only way to save The Rook is
rookie but then I take on A7 I'll put
the duck back on C8 and The Rook will be
trapped
and the duck can't really do much about
it I don't think
oh but the Knight defends a rook
so I guess I'm just winning a pawn
yeah I'll win the pawn
and maybe I'll go after C7 like Knight
B5 coming
oh I could play
how fancy do I want to be
now let's keep the pressure
so now I'm threatening to take here and
then play duck B7 or take here
even simpler
so an engine Block's gonna play duck B7
to defend
foreign
but yeah it's already a difficult
position black is getting low on time
okay Doug B7 good move but now I'm gonna
do this and then this
so trying to attack from multiple
directions
oh a queen C8
all right let's take the Knight and then
play this
and then this and then this
okay
a pleasant game
GG
yeah
okay I'm looking for high rated
opponents I'll play Chuck GM
I wonder if they're from the Czech
Republic
okay let's play D4
I'll mix off the way I take take
opponents for future games
Checkers Slovakia
it's probably where Checkers was
invented right
Okay so
this is actually looking like a really
nice opening because I'll play this and
then duck D5 preventing Knight D5
and now the night the Black Knights can
be forced to one of these sad squares
I've been white the last at least three
games in a row
it does feel like white has a reasonable
advantage
at least in a lot of these openings
okay there's a cool idea
oh boy okay
I can't resist I'm going to take on F7
you don't see this in normal chess but
in Duck chess
this is going to be fun
so I put the dock on G5 guaranteeing
Knight G5
oh but black is guaranteeing King Yates
oh so devious
well I guess I'll I'll play this and
then guarantee Pawnee six
it's getting really spicy
yeah Pawnee six and then
doc CA chopping the bishop
that's a cool idea
could you do this tomorrow also
are people becoming more attached to
duck chess
I think once in a while it's it's fun to
rekindle an old passion for a variant
so this is actually a confusing position
so I could
I could take the bishop win back
material
but I could also
play this move
try and win the queen
or The Rook let's play this move
and then this
yeah trying to use the duck to its full
full extent
okay black sacrifices a queen
make sure the Rook can't take
now black does have two minor pieces for
the queen
and my Bishop's blocked my queen is
blocked
and start with B4
and duck
probably duck D7
ensuring node Knight D7
and now the duck is pinned to the king
so Black's gonna have to put the duck on
the D file probably back to D2
but anyway to exploit that maybe Rook B1
and then
F6 preventing this
King's still attacks
B5
I think I'll just play A3
I'm not the highest rated player on the
site
after this game I can show the
leaderboard stats
okay so attacking this and potentially
targeting the bishop
okay so this is a very common graphic I
take the bishop and I block
the long range defense
no mercy
I don't understand this game yeah the
rules are here on the sidebar
but um it does take some practice to
fully understand
just know that the doc blocks it blocks
things can't be captured
every turn we we make a normal chess
move and we move the dock to a new
Square
that's pretty much the
the rules of Dr of duck chess
so I'm blocking The Rook don't want to
lose a pawn
gotta watch my time
yeah I have an extra Queen but there's
only so much I can do with extra Queen
take and this
maybe I'll win the pawn
it's so risky to take the pawn though
okay
so there's two attackers let's play F3
can you pre-dock oh like pre-move the
duck I think you can only pre-move
uh the chess moves as far as I know
no yeah I can only like pre-move a chess
move
oh
[Music]
okay let's take the Knight
now black could take back and put the
duck on G6 but then I'll win the pawn
I'm down a little bit of time
so let's move a bit quicker
okay win this Pawn this Rook battery
really doesn't mean anything
because I'll keep putting the duck back
on the G file
i pre-move the Queen
and duck B6 is coming oh maybe not
oh wait what I just hung the pawn
oops
okay removing the bishop
I'm panicking a little bit
ah
I have 10 seconds left
opponent's getting low on time too
yeah
I'm not making moves fast enough
or am I
okay I won The Rook
trying to make progress hey it's a free
King okay
that time I found the free King
I think that was the first game that
ended with
not fogging
okay I'll start from the top playing
Elijah
good games on my opponent though that
was a good fight
I won the queen earlier but they fought
very uh
very well
okay
so playing at two nights
yeah this is kind of the go-to opening
well especially when I can't move my
e-pawn
kind of defaulting to the setup
yeah in order for the bishop to develop
it probably has to feel kind of
which we will see
now in normal chess I'd love to take the
pawn and use the pin but white would
take back and put the duck on the
diagonal
so let's
I don't think I want a castle let's just
uh
and gradually get some space
might also develop my Bishop
so the diagonal
yes we keep kind of treating
the placement of a duck between D3 and
E6
like this whole game so far the duck has
only been on these two squares
so we're both forced to play around
these squares
and I'm not castling because there's a
chance I might start storming
on the king side
Eric is pretty much the Samuel quaxen of
sports
I'll take that as a compliment
okay so G5 is my plan G5 G4 attack
maybe Castle queenside Rook Gian Etc
challenge only put the duck on the same
square the entire game
so far I'm fulfilling that challenge
it's having connection issues
okay let's see let's see if I can
accomplish that this game
but that's difficult to to do if the
point knows
my limits
interesting move okay let's
let's make things spicy so I'm losing
this Pawn but maybe winning this pond
but so far the challenge is going well
a nice list of duck D3
okay I'm gonna Castle first
want to get the other Rook involved
now sometimes when it comes to Rooks
the duck can block
one file if it wants but it can't block
two files so I want to make use of the
the H and G files
eventually want to play G4
okay Bishop H6
now this is slightly problematic let's
play this
so I'm going after this Pawn because
black can't play D3 they can play F3
though
if it goes back to E6 I'm in the windy
too
okay that's a free Bishop
now duck D3 too strong
such a useful Square
okay now there's really no reason to put
the dock here if I was maybe there is
maybe I want a Target C2
I think if my opponent knew that I'm
putting the duck on D3 every move
they could probably take advantage of it
and beat me
although here the positions becoming
stronger and stronger
I'm gonna go after the d-pawn
and now
uh let's take that
okay wait a minute I want to play Queen
D3
but
then I can't play duck D3
Queen D3 is just game over but I guess
I'll fulfill my challenge
wait now I'm just blocking myself though
maybe I can play
this and then duck D3
no I can't play Rook D okay I'll take
the pawn I guess
that's annoying I can't use that square
for my pieces
well Doug G1 would be dugmate but
fair enough
okay
mission accomplished
oh let's play jacks for the pro we
played in um
in
was it Norway craigero we played like in
the serious classical tournament
but now it's time for
uh Syria's duck chess
no more of this challenge of putting the
duck on the same square
although it's not a bad strategy at the
beginning of the game
yeah candidate master
Jack story was beating me in Norway we
had a crazy crazy game
okay so I can't develop the bishop
it actually might make sense to put the
duck on G6
or on G7
although
now let's keep the the pawn blocked
okay so I've I guess I allowed Bishop G4
wait what should I do there
well I prevented castling I lost the
train of thought
I think what I'll do is play Knight G1
duck F3
it looks ridiculous but I want to
exploit the bishop here
maybe not a great idea
realizing I should have played duck E2
to allow the bishop to move
I'm block taking some time
oh
okay it's getting practical so if I take
I can't oh that's a good move
maybe I take here
take and then talk F3
and then the plan is to play Rook B1
after I lose a bishop
and now I can't even put the duck back
though
because I lose my queen
but I'll play H3
and basically what's happened I lost a
pawn but
I got the two nights
okay
and now I'm threatening G4 so
yeah maybe there's some compensation
[Music]
yeah G4 is prevented
but if the duck is preventing G4 then I
can kind of develop freely it should be
okay
yeah maybe there is a similar tactic in
the previous game
but maybe not
oh dear
that's almost checkmate almost dug me I
have to play King E2
like I have to be really really careful
here
let's focus jackster is playing very
strong
foreign
this
I think I'm trapping the bishop
allowing Queen F4 though so it's getting
messy
but I'm pretty sure I'm winning the
bishop
um
I don't know where to put the duck
D2 wait what move do I want to guarantee
E1
or do I want to stop maybe Duck back
so my D4 we trade
this is scary
um
my box threatening to essentially check
Maybe
so I have this and then this
is my this is my Escape Route this looks
like Checkmate but then I'm guaranteed
King F1
it's going to come down to time I think
okay let's play this
and then this
E5 is coming
consolidated
how to do this
okay slightly dirty flag
opponent played really well though
move the duck far away yeah that's a
dirty trick I could have put the duck on
A1 to
maximize my opponents
distance for the mouse
oh Jacksonville the pro is playing on a
mouse pad
yeah that's gotta be tough
wait mouse pad or a trackpad
yeah 3-2 is a tough time control
[Music]
good luck to cod fish
do a couple more
as their duck 960. yeah you can probably
combine any variants with duck chess
duck atomic
duck house
C4
okay well um
oh yeah Dock Of War
that'd be interesting
I think there should be some analysis
board
but there's no engine here
a four-player duck chest
okay I'll cause some annoyance for my
opponent
oh no my duck video incoming what should
the title of the the duck chess video be
oh no my duck a long time no duck chess
duck chess is back
to play this move in this move
yeah normal chest openings are a bit
different in Duck chess like if you try
and play the London the opponent can
just stop you
put a duck on F4 and then no London for
you
all right let's control the center
any dark chess opening Theory books you
would recommend
don't think there's been any books on
Duck chess thus far maybe some business
opportunity though
oh there goes a pawn
pretty sure that pawn is poisonous
though because now the bishop is stuck
on the edge of the board
and it's under constant Eye Of The Rook
and the duck will have to go back to H6
but then G6 is coming
so I don't think white can actually save
the bishop
this is a very common theme
where if you go too deep into the Pawn's
territory it's so much easier to trap
pieces
especially Bishops because the duck just
blocks the diagonal of retreat
uh let's play this
yeah if the opponent played duck G6 I
would have taken the bishop and blocked
the queen
okay I have a very devious plan
get ready for it
it's not easy to stop
really not easy to stop
it's smothered duckmates
that's game over can pre-move this
no mercy
okay good game
okay that was a lot of duck chess let me
check my duck ranking
leaderboard
Blitz
I'm not on the leaderboard
I guess I'm not active enough
I would be number four on the
leaderboard if my rating was there
so I think it's time to wrap things up I
will return for normal chess coming soon
um I'm probably due for some like slower
instructive rapid chess
so do stay tuned